what's popping has Guardians it's me Mt
and welcome back to the heavy spoiler
show and holy moly was episode s of this
new season of what if such a fun
freaking time man getting to see a whole
new side of the goddess of death as she
learned a much needed lesson in Mercy
was super satisfying but definitely not
as satisfying as seeing Shu wenwu punch
the all father of Asgard in the freaking
face that was freaking badass man like
how damn do I love a good crossover
episode and this episode for sure did
deliver with such a fire team up so
let's just go ahead and break this
entire episode down together shall we
Mard babies but first you guys know the
drill hitting that like button and
subscribing really helps Paul and I grow
the heavy spoilers channel so if you are
a proud member of the spoiler side Squad
doing one or both of those things would
be a super quick and easy way to make
two nerdy Lads happy but anyways this
episode of course begins with Asgardian
art detailing Odin and hela's bloody
conquest of the nine Realms imagery that
MCU Watchers have definitely seen before
in Thor Ragnarok when Hela revealed
asgard's true dark history to her not so
loyal servant Scourge The Executioner
and while the version of the mural that
we see in what if is a faithful
Recreation of the one that we saw in
live action one detail that I noticed
that was different between the two is
this Halo of light that Hela has framed
around her head in the bottom right
corner here in the animation that's a
detail specifically added for this
episode possibly serving as a bit of
foreshadowing for hela's eventual
acceptance of a lifestyle of light and
mercy through the purification of her
mind then we transition to a recreation
of Thor's banishment scene from the
first Thor movie but instead of Thor
having his PO Stripped Away and exiled
to Earth until a valuable lesson is
learned Thor's secret older sister Hela
is in that particular Hot Seat in this
universe and I really appreciated how
The Watcher briefly showed us the exact
moment that 616 Hela got sent to Hell by
Odin before being introduced to the
events of this alternate universe
because actually getting to see that
Hela stood in the same spot that Thor
did and was spouting the very same type
of arrogant and violent rhetoric that
would undoubtedly lead Asgard into more
battles of Bloodshed it really does help
explain why Odin did what he did with
Thor's banishment because he saw a lot
of Hela within Thor because much like
Odin tells a young Thor and Loki in the
first Thor movie a wise ruler never
actually seeks out War but Hela was too
damn eager to lead an army of as many as
guardian soldiers as it took to reach
outwards beyond the nine Realms and
Conquer other unclaimed Realms in the
cosmos an ambition that liveaction Hela
Echoes when she first arrives on Asgard
in Thor Ragnarok so in order to follow
through on those Ambitions Hela
foolishly hurls Muir at Odin only for
him to catch Muir with one hand and
destroy it just like Hela does to the
hammer and Thor Ragnarok which I thought
was a really fun callback and as a
consequence in order to save save the
lives of his valued Asgardian soldiers
from being infected by the insatiable
Ambitions of the Living Weapons of war
that he created he put his love for his
children aside and cast them out in
order to protect Asgard from their
radically foolish ideologies but anyways
as Hela is being grounded by her dad in
a big way we get the confirmation that
hela's Crown functions a lot like Thor's
hammer does as Hela is now completely
unable to pull out an infinite amount of
necros swords out of her astounding as
guardian ass as soon as Odin takes her
helmet away from her like I very much
suspected this to be the case after the
chachala starlord episode from last
season had the collector wielding hela's
Dark Matter necros sword Powers as soon
as he grabbed hela's helmet from his
collection to fight yandu and chachala
but anyways hel's helmet of course lands
right in front of the armies of Shu Wen
wo's 10 Rings during wwu's super early
conquering days roughly around the year
1000 and I only say that because the
very beginning of the shangi movie shows
a flashback of when mu's attack on the
armies of the sjuk Empire an Empire that
was active between 1037 and 1194 and
since wwu in this episode wears the same
Garb and has the same Army that we saw
in that scene combined with the fact
that we know that whenw first discovered
the Rings 1,000 years in the past around
that time it is very safe to say that
this episode takes place sometime within
that time period but anyways when Hela
is unable to lift her helmet from the
ground she screams at a rainy thundering
sky in anguish just like 616 Thor did in
Thor one right after he tried to do the
same with his hammer at the shield
containment site and while Hela herself
wasn't exactly surrounded by Shield
agents like Thor was in the movie she
sort of kind of was in a way as we learn
in this episode that when moo function
the 10 Rings a lot like the peacekeeping
Force Shield will eventually become in
the distant future so the 10 rings are
very much the shield of this era or at
the very least the closest thing to
Shield that the Earth has at this moment
anyway and as the story continues news
Hela is of course brought to wwu's
Tanner Ring's headquarters where she is
immediately invited to dinner during
that dinner W Ru proposes an alliance
but in response to that Alliance Hela
opens up to wwu about how her father
treated her more like a weapon for
Conquest more so than a daughter causing
one moo to assure Hela that he is not
her father but that she can call him
daddy
anytime I'm just kidding he didn't say
that last part but I don't know man
something tells me that these two
definitely got it on after they managed
to take down the ruler of the known
universe of light together I mean there
is truly nothing like usurping a throne
to get the sex drive going you know what
I'm saying after all there is no one
hornier than
Hela get it because because of the horns
but anyways I found it super ironic that
Hela was having that particular
conversation with wwu specifically
because as we learned in the shangi
movie when who pretty much treated his
own son in a very similar fashion to how
Odin did with with Hela treating his son
as nothing more than another weapon for
his own selfish purposes however due to
Shu WMU not having experienced the
trauma of losing his wife in this
universe yet the younger version of WMU
has not yet become the cold heartless
vengful person that would push his son
to become an assassin but anyways after
Hela betrays wnu and makes her escape
from the 10 Rings compound she of course
runs into an imprisoned Morris who
apparently would have been imprisoned
for the next 1,000 years if this was the
616 universe but luckily Hela is able to
break his ass face out and make their
way to the bamboo forest that protects
the entrance to Dragon Land on PBS Kids
just kidding it's t out but it's
basically Dragon Land just with a
significant lack of Zack and Wheezy
however one particular thing I found
interesting about hela's arrival to this
bamboo forest is that this Forest very
likely should not have been moving at
all because we learned from W Wu and
shongi that this particular magic bamboo
for Forest only really shows the way to
Tallow once a year on a Chinese holiday
known as Ching Ming J or tomb sweeping
day I completely apologize if I just
butchered that name but basically this
Festival is a tradition where the people
of China take the time to honor those
ancestors who have passed on by cleaning
up their grave sites and leaving special
offerings it's a festival that occurs
every year on the first day of the fifth
solar term of the Chinese Luna solar
calendar basically around Springtime so
unless Hela so happened to arrive to
this magic bamboo forest during the
exact time frame needed for the forest
to reveal the path to tallo she
shouldn't really have gotten as far as
she did but honestly who the hell cares
anything can happen and what if it's a
cartoon and this being the case Hela
arrives in Tallow and is told by a woman
named ja that talo is actually a realm
that acts as a protective boundary for
the main Universe against forces of
Darkness that emerge from what she
called the underworld however exactly
what the underworld is in the MCU is
still a mystery considering that we know
that Hela is native to her home realm of
Asgard which is as opposite to an
underworld as one can get considering
that Asgard sits at the very top of
everything so if I were to venture a
guess as to what this woman meant by
Underworld I would assume that ja could
be talking about the shadow realm
introduced in Thor love and thunder as
that is a realm where dark dragons dwell
inside of the dark insides of moons with
the dweller in darkness possibly being
one of those dragons native to the
shadow realm and I wouldn't be surprised
if the realm of Hell actually resides
within the shadow realm itself as the
prisoners of Hell appear to live in a
colorless grayscale environment just
like the shadow realm has so since North
myths usually associate the goddess Hela
with the realm hell the people of Tallow
probably figured that she was from the
shadow realm too but that's just
speculation of course but another Super
interesting piece of information that we
get right after this is how Odin's
future wife frigga is not not hela's
mother at all but is actually just a
woman that Odin started to date around
the time Hela got banished from Asgard
so not only does this make Hela Thor's
half sister but it also confirms
something that I suspected for a long
while Thor might actually be half human
I mean Hela literally calls frigga a
woman instead of a God and we already
know from frig's past appearances in MCU
movies that frigga was originally raised
as a witch meaning that she was likely
not born a god at all the party Thor
episode of what if season 1 shows frga
actively leaving the realm of Asgard in
order to go visit her old witch sisters
in another realm and I think that other
realm could have actually been midgard
with those witches living somewhere on
Earth but that's just a theory a fraking
FR Theory but anyways we then of course
get an appearance by the great protector
Dragon of Tallow who flies by as a
warning to Hela to chill out with the
hel Shenanigans while she's in town no
henigan over here then as the the scene
changes to a heimdal informing Odin of
hela's complete disappearance from their
Universe heimdal states that the tan
rings have the capability to kill even
the gods which is a huge piece of MCU
lore that we didn't previously know
before because the only real God killer
that we've known about before this is of
course the Stormbreaker Hammer that Thor
forged in Infinity War However the fact
that heimdal just knew that a weapon
that strong existed on Earth and yet
waited that long to tell Odin about it
is kind of weird to me but hey who am I
to tell heimall how to do his job but
anyways now that we know that these
rings are coveted by even the gods of
the MCU themselves I'm really interested
to see what this could possibly mean for
shun's future in MCU 616 because I'm
sure a ton of cosmic beings are going to
want a piece of that 10 Ring action now
that those rings are apparently sending
a signal out to the universe absolutely
doxing the hell out of shani's location
at all times but anyways I really enjoy
the training sequence that follows this
because it was really dope to see Hela
being forced to break down her
motivations for her constant need to
conquer Hela revealing that she only
wants to gain the power to overthrow her
father and Conquer The Cosmos because
she has a deep desire for True Freedom
was super great and deeply reflective of
Loki's own journey of Enlightenment and
self-discovery that he went through over
the course of the Loki series both Hela
and Loki were lonely Gods who were
treated like ponds by their flawed
father Odin with Loki himself only
really having been taken by Odin as a
political maneuver to hopefully Foster
peace between Asgard and yodenheim both
of these mistreated children just wanted
to be free to forge their own paths and
so they both chased that freedom the
only way they were taught how through
war games and bloodshed just like their
father did it is only when Hela learns
to quiet her rageful mind that she's
able to truly see that she doesn't
actually want to be an executioner of
War but a liberator of lives and it is
that very perspective shift that allows
her to wear her helmet once more but
this time with a major color change
reflecting her inner shift from Darkness
to light very Gand off the gray to Gand
off the white type fives and finally
when Hela and her Cosmic 10 Ring
liberating Army appear at the very end
of the episode they arrive over gamora's
home world of Zen hubber during the
exact moment that Thanos was about to do
the classic adop and Slaughter on Gamora
and her people respectively completely
halting the Mad Titan quest for balance
before he could ever assemble all the
ston truly the ultimate life-saving act
for a reformed goddess of death on the
side of light but anyways that is it for
this breakdown of episode 7 of season 2
of what if man I freaking love what if
so much I hope the show never stops you
can follow me at mastertainment on
Twitter Instagram YouTube or wherever I
am on the internet including the
Guardians of the paly podcast where me
my friends Whitney and Tommy talk about
all the new fun things in Marvel and
nerd culture but with an emphasis on fun
and friendships so if you like either of
those things subscribe to the Guardians
of the paly today but most importantly
you can subscribe to heavy spoilers here
on YouTube and when you do make sure you
hit that notification Bell so that you
can always get notifications for when we
upload new things but again thank you
guys so much for watching this video you
guys are amazing and I will see you guys
later goodbye happy New Year
y'all